and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a are tonight's review puppets
bossy bottom
oh my god DZ the greatest movie I've
ever seen in my life
boiler Z there's this frog named
Constantine who apparently is so evil
they made them at door back ya know
Reese movie and the bad news is he looks
exactly like another frog Garrison
Keillor but also Kermit oh my god what
are the odds of that happening except in
the prints of the pulp here Ernest goes
to jail and 100% of every 80's and 90's
cartoons I ever came up so Constantine
teams up with Ricky Jabez who has the
diabolical plan of doing his humor ones
without pissing people off or as he
likes to call it the Emmys take two and
they plan to take her metaphor place in
with Constantine why so they can use
their world tour as a cover to spend
lots of money to get lots of reviews and
pack the seats to steal lots of money
which apparently they already have oh
one of them up it's gonna do well I'm
gonna take a will kiss and say a lot of
fourth-wall jokes hi did you know that
we're Muppets and we're in a Muppet
movie
well yes I did that's like 90% of our
material folks so they take Herman and
they throw them in a great big prison in
Russia and their security guard Tina Fey
is like welcome to my fatal Saturday
Night Live character who know what are
you gonna do to me and out of nowhere
song sequent followed by a bajillion
cameos oh so you mean like every scene
before this pretty much well it turns
out Tina Fey has the massive hots for
Kermit the Frog which is unlikely seeing
how they don't allow homosexuality in
Russia Ethel our amphibian allottee
which sounds like a mortal kombat
finishing move killer but Constantine
has to distract the rest of the Muppets
so he has Miss Piggy to marry him which
I thought they already did in Muppets
Take Manhattan
oh is that just part of the ship wait if
it was haven't the Muppets like met
themselves 20 times in these movies
everyone's upset about spider-man
rebooting they never point out that the
muff is reboot every sequel it's like a
kid's version of the Evil Dead movies
which might be a Nazi moron the more I
think about it but then does that brat
how to place my pit points out the
Constantinus in Kermit and so they go to
the Russian prison and break out and
Tina Fey is like mom i won
love I was made any country necessary to
find his Juke has been abandoned due to
the fact I never watched TV and was not
aware of current events I was not aware
that Putin himself he's actually a fraud
so Miss Piggy is about to marry
Constantine when she finds out that
Kermit comes in and she's like hurry
number one are you Kermit
of course I am even though I sound like
bad boy rantin crazy coming number two
are you correct as long as you ask me
not to marry you keeping one the most
bizarre cat tease is going on in puppet
history high five so when you say the DC
but then evil Tina Fey comes in I am
here to be tagged on threat when we will
fight you with our obvious moral lesson
will it be dragged out past four minutes
isn't it always
Oh Mimi Russia can find it it it's hard
to have compassion and kindness for all
of God's living creature I get totally
didn't watch any TV recently that can be
hilarious a Trekkie for was supposed to
be a comedy show The Muppets do one more
show and Russia all the cameos are
horribly CG Don a wall and nobody ever
questions what happened to Jason Segel
or Amy Adams Hey
so this Muppet movie was really funny
it's like the first one had a lot of
heart like the first Muppet movie and
this one had a lot of jokes like the
second Muppet movie which means the
third Muppet movie should probably be
mediocre then they'll start ripping off
literary classic destroy the franchise
by going into space or dirt in the grave
with horrible TV specials make a
comeback on YouTube in then it all
starts over again
well I think I just figured out what the
Rainbow Connection is the lovers the
dreamers and repeats hey as long as you
use that term curry Muppet again I'm set
you mean that wasn't a muppet I will
never believe that this is jittery
buncee yeah gosh I come on have a guy
owe me yeah come on change come on I can
get some celebrity cameos only sure
usually ask me for money